Gabe Grant another student collaborator
who is
Jacob andreas's students and uh Tundra
stren a student also co-advised by Josh
as well as Noah Goodman my advisor
vikash and Jacob address
um so our broader goal today in this
talk is actually going to be to reflect
based on many of the recent advances
that we all know of modeling language
but I think also drawing on evidence
from toolkits other toolkits in AI
um and and evidence from cognitive
science and from Neuroscience on kind of
the broader spectrum of different ways
that we might think about building
intelligent architectures that use and
produce and learn from language as well
as more generally I think what role
language might play or could play in A
computational system that we say thinks
and obviously this is a question that
many people in this room but many other
people who probably aren't in this room
have thought about from philosophers of
language to linguists and
neuroscientists and we thought it
actually might be a useful exercise to
kind of start by reflecting on the
underlying answers to this question that
are or aren't suggested by some of the
most prominent directions that we're
taking in AI research right now
and of course right one of the reasons
why we're even asking this question at
this scale what is the role of language
in intelligence is in large part driven
by this remarkable observation that we
all know about from just a few years ago
which is um you know if you train these
large and specifically Transformer based
neural architectures as language models
just to do this next word prediction
task you know with enough language data
they start to show behaviors that really
suggests that there's something more
than language at play they look like
they're thinking
um you know they can induce patterns
from just a few examples in data or they
can even read the definitions of totally
novel words like zakar torte in context
and produce realistic sentences that
appear as if they understand how to use
those words immediately and so a lot of
the excitement I think it's fair to say
around language models is that maybe for
the first time we're seeing something
that is offering a scalable route
towards implementing more generally
intelligent architectures just by
directly scaling or largely by directly
scaling the amount of language data that
they're being trained to predict
all right so what is the underlying idea
here what does this have to say about
language well I think it's fair to say
that one of the dominant hypotheses
that's underlying why we were even
starting to see some this behavior
um rests on kind of a two-part idea one
is something about the nature of
language itself right it's the
suggestion that uh language is
sufficiently diverse and so broad maybe
because we suspect that humans Express
so much of their thoughts on such a
diverse range of their thoughts and
language that being able to perfectly
solve this task to be a perfect language
model or at least a really good one is
essentially a a an AGI complete task uh
and maybe also one that conveniently
unlike other kinds of tasks like
predicting all the videos in the world
all the YouTube videos in the world we
have maybe efficient architectures to do
and enough data to do
um and I think it's worth noting that
you know this doesn't actually really
have to be a particularly strong
hypothesis about what it is
computationally that thinking looks like
um or even how language necessarily is
implicated internally uh inside the
computational processes that we call
thinking rather it's really just a
hypothesis about the nature of the
language modeling task itself
and I think what a lot of people in this
room would agree now
um is that you know well that might be
true about the language modeling task in
principle much of the most exciting
research that we're seeing using LMS
right now actually isn't predicated on
really The Hope or the idea that just by
scaling to more and more data we're
going to expect Transformers trained and
used in this way to actually solve that
task or become perfect next word
prediction models and the intuition
behind that which I think many people
have pointed out comes both from the way
in which Transformers work right their
Auto regressive language models that are
doing a fixed finite amount of internal
computation that only scales based on
the previous linguistic context and it
doesn't really make sense that you know
of course you can pose questions in
language like arbitrarily difficult math
problems or planning problems that
intuitively require an amount of
computation whose complexity doesn't
actually depend linearly on the previous
token context
um and I think that's been matched
empirically by lots of different
observations about which kinds of
sentences are hard to complete if you
treat them as next word prediction tasks
in this way right hard arbitrary math
problems or planning problems like these
right so um
some of you know if you're thinking
about uh the role of language why why is
language why are language models so big
right now as oh well language just has
all the evidence necessary to train uh
to train something to think
um
like Leo said that's not actually
committing to any hypothesis about sort
of how language is used internally in
thinking the Transformers computations
are not necessarily doing anything
linguistic uh as it's Computing the
distribution of the next word but more
recently we've seen people use language
models to solve these harder tasks by
letting them think more and what letting
a Transformer think more means is
letting it generate more tokens
um so in this view thinking doesn't
necessarily emerge just as predicting
the next token
um
rather thinking happens in language
right it happens by sort of uh producing
a chain of thoughts or using a scratch
pad or deciding that you're going to
invoke a calculator or write some code
and execute the code
um and uh
the sort of hypothesis embodied I think
by this line of work is that the role of
language and intelligence architecture
is bigger that language or some kind of
like running monologue of language is
the central controller of thought and
thinking is taking place primarily in
language
um
and you know
what's maybe striking about these
proposals is that if you ask most
cognitive scientists or neuroscientists
they'd probably say this isn't the role
that language plays in relation to
general intelligence in humans or at
least you know it's not the dominant
hypothesis
um until just a few years ago this
probably wouldn't have been the role
that many AI researchers would have
necessarily posited for language as you
know the main controller or the main
substrate of a running monologue that
controls all thinking
um and so we thought we'd review some of
the background for what language seems
to look like in humans as a basis for
informing how we might build
architectures that better capture those
more human-like roles for language and
thinking
yeah and so I just want to be clear that
we're going to do kind of a quick
background on some of the
neuroscientific and cognitive evidence
about what language might looks like in
people and our goal really isn't to push
back in any way against these other
kinds of paradigms for where orange
might fit in it's rather to present you
know at a mode where we're really
thinking a lot about Skilling up
language models as the other as one
really dominant role what are other
um Roots might be because it doesn't
seem like that that really matches
um a different prominent intelligent
architecture that's sitting here in the
room today so one source of evidence for
the role that language appears to play
in human cognition
um comes from neuroimaging data fmri
data suggesting how language is
processed in the human brain and at this
point
um convergent Imaging data from many
people
um including EV federenko at MIT Stan
dehane and recent graduate students in
our department uh Kyle malwald and Anya
ibanova suggests that human brains have
this language specific Network that
handles many of the tasks that we
associate with language it's activated
when people do tasks like listening to
sentences or reading them or speaking or
writing words
um and this is not just an
english-specific Network the same
general region is activated no matter
what language someone is speaking it
even fires when they're producing
constructed languages for people who
come to learn and become fluent in
languages like Dothraki or Klingon
um and right what is it that this
language network does well increasingly
one dominant hypothesis is that it
actually does do something like next
word prediction
um and in fact among many other kinds of
alternative models like uh you know
people were earlier for a long time I've
been trying to do things like align word
to back to the brain Transformer
architectures really do seem to be among
the best models that we have right now
of the neural activity of this language
Network specifically when they're
trained on next word prediction tasks
and not other linguistic tasks like um
noi
but I think what we see in this
neuroimaging evidence also highlights
the ways in which the role of this human
language Network probably is not as the
controller or the central seat of
cognition it's selective for language
and it isn't involved in many other
kinds of thinking activities
um even ones that might seem to involve
symbols like solving math problems or
reasoning about logic and physics and
social reasoning those invoke other
reasoning regions of the brain and
language interfaces modularly with them
interface very generally with them but
it doesn't seem to be where the bulk of
thinking is taking place
oh yes oh yeah I just had a question
about the next word prediction finding
so did you also try to say like math uh
word prediction and this is actually
where's the next word yeah so I think
they do compare or like close tasks are
one of the alternates that they're
looking for and also yeah people should
feel free to just shut out as we've been
doing all along
so also uh right actually you can see
adult patients that suffer Strokes that
only damage this area of their brain and
we find that they can still think uh
about well they they can't comprehend
spoken language but they can think still
think about all these different kinds of
tasks for instance in different medium
like they can draw physical inferences
from videos that they're watching
uh and conversely it may be most
tantalizingly it's actually also
possible to sustain localized damage
that leaves you still able to produce
these long very relatively fluent and
quite syntactically coherent sentences
almost as if they're maybe just like a
very rudimentary and local word based
language model while not really
conditioning meaningfully on what
someone else is saying so they say do
you like it here in Kansas City and the
uh this person says yes I am
um or really producing sentences that
are obviously more globally meaningful
or goal directed towards the question
and I don't want us to over index on
those results but they kind of fit in
with this more coherent picture
and in many ways I think this kind of
recent evidence from Neuroscience
actually supports the broader picture of
human cognition and the place of
language in it that most cognitive
scientists and many linguists have
already believed based on what we see
and have come to learn through
developmental science uh studying how
kids think and World Language seems to
fit into that picture right so a broad
body of work at this point suggests that
infants well before they learn language
of any kind or are speaking already
independently perform many of the tasks
I think we associate with coherent
thinking from reasoning about physics to
planning to drawing causal and
probabilistic inferences
and language seems to be something that
humans learn and scaffold on top of this
structured basis for thinking we take
much less input data to learn to produce
fluent language than a large language
model and you know humans that actually
aren't exposed to any language input at
all so famously there are these deaf
children in Nicaragua who grow up in
isolated hearing families actually
spontaneously come to produce early sign
languages as a product of trying to
communicate events that bear many of the
Hallmarks of the syntax that we
associate of our own natural languages
like distinguishing between the subject
who's punching and the person who's
getting punched
um suggesting that in many ways the
language we produce somehow externalizes
the underlying structure of the thought
that we already have
and of course there are many other
animals that we associate as being
intelligent in some way and that have
been modeled using the models um that we
associate with uh you know probabilistic
reasoning and planning um that don't use
language at all so it doesn't feel like
languages by any means necessary
um for for what we think of as thought
so you know formalizing this picture of
an intelligent system one that's shared
across animals and non-linguistic
infants and maybe captures some of the
computations invoked in many of those
thinking tasks that uh that don't
involve the language network uh in in
our brains is both the central goal of a
lot of cognitive science and um has been
a historic motivation for diverse Fields
within AI before the current sort of
llm-centric moment so you know if you
open up Russell and norveg's textbook uh
AI a modern approach you'll see an
equation like this that's supposed to
sort of capture what we believe about
how intelligence Works
um uh computationally or computational
model of intelligence where the idea is
that an intelligent agent is one that
has sort of structured internal World
models that can be updated based on
observations of the world and uh in
which we can sort of predict the results
of our actions
um that the agent has some sort of
values or does desires that are captured
in some kind of utility function that
the agent can do probabilistic reasoning
over its observations and the possible
actions it might take uh and and what
their expected utilities are and that it
can do some kind of planning to optimize
uh the value of the toxins yeah
or descriptive statement like is it the
case that like we are defining
intelligent agent to be having this kind
of property or it's like
like 800 architecture we should have
these yeah so I think some it's a great
question I think some of the work
definitely is coming at it from a
normative perspective you know this is
like a definition of what rational
action might look like right but I think
there is a lot of work in computational
cognitive science that sort of in
various domains has collected a lot of
evidence that people uh either like
recognize this as normative or behave
like this
um in computation you know according to
the limits of what they can do
computationally
um
so uh
the you know in this architecture the
controller for thinking would be some
kind of system that's capable of General
World modeling and probabilistic
reasoning or planning and utility
maximization rather than sort of uh a
primarily linguistic system necessarily
um now largely attempts in artificial
intelligence to directly implement this
equation by building out components that
sort of map onto the different uh the
different elements of this equation
um have struggled to match the
computational efficiency and the
generality of natural intelligence but
we have seen over the past couple
decades or so the emergence of this new
class of tools called probabilistic
programming languages for building
software that can solve probabilistic
reasoning tasks at least in limited
domains
um and sorry
and these languages have been applied to
create systems that do everything from
perceiving cluttered 3D scenes uh more
accurately sometimes than object
detector neural Nets to interpreting and
predicting economic Trends uh more
accurately than leading industry
Solutions like Facebook neural profit
and these probabilistic programming
systems are enabling these applications
with two key technical features they
feature modeling languages that let
users Express complicated probabilistic
models of the world as programs making
it easy to write down Rich probabilistic
models that are defined in terms of
expressive program-like components and
so for example the probabilistic models
Behind These example applications are
defined in terms of 3D renderers
symbolic planners scientific simulators
and so on and the second thing that
probabilistic programming systems do is
that they automate various mathematical
operations on these models and that
automation makes it possible for users
to concisely implement sophisticated
algorithms for probabilistic reasoning
such as the variety of Monte Carlo and
variational inference algorithms that
power these example applications so one
way of thinking about these tools is as
uh you know kind of like Pi torch or
tensorflow but instead of writing
differentiable models and doing
optimization you're writing
probabilistic models and doing various
probabilistic reasoning tasks
I'm so so far these AI engineering
efforts haven't really made contact with
language with the sort of language model
uh part of AI
and much like there hasn't yet been a
concerted effort to take this classical
picture of intelligence architecture and
figure out how language might be richly
integrated into it so for the rest of
the talk today we're going to explore
two different approaches for thinking
about where language might fit into this
picture and approach so broadly uh Leo
is going to begin by talking about how
an intelligent agent might incorporate
lots of externally produced languages uh
you know explanations observations
questions how an agent can incorporate
all of those forms of language into the
way that it updates its beliefs and
decides how to act in the world then
I'll talk a bit about systems that
leverage language as a tool for thinking
uh within its models of the world or its
probabilistic reasoning algorithms and
each of these corresponds to very recent
uh preprints of work so I also want to
give a disclaimer we should really
emphasize that both are preliminary
proposals uh and we're giving a very
kind of speculative talk not scaled
architectural Solutions
cool right so the first person this
portion of this talk is summarizing work
if you want to read more you can find
this for a long paper from word models
to World models
um that's up on archive and this is
primarily done with another student
who's not here today Gabe Grant
um and as I just mentioned the context
for this work is thinking about how we
can build systems that capture the
breadth of which all the external
language we hear seems to inform at
least our human thinking
and what's clear right is that this role
seems to be very broad if we take the
basic model of an agent with beliefs and
goals well it seems like there's an
incredibly diverse range of situations
in which we can update our beliefs about
a situation from observations that we
Express in language or in which the
goals of our thoughts are to answer
questions that we specify linguistically
and these might implicate our knowledge
of other agents drawing on our intuitive
psychology to reason about what they
think and what they'll do or you know we
can talk about the physical world around
us what we perceive and ask questions
that require us to reason about what we
see and draw in our physical intuitions
and of course one of the remarkable
things while we're also excited about
language is that doesn't just run what
we already know it's this means by which
humans seem to learn and pass on
profoundly new knowledge whether that's
new Concepts
um that we Define in words or learn from
words to really profound new theories
and conceptual systems right much of
what we know about the world the fact
that there are Wars what wars are legal
systems Sciences comes from information
that it feels that we acquire from
language in some way
um but how do we do that well I think
one long-standing lens for thinking
about language
um that's kind of persisted before uh
the the llm-based moment is that what
language is is this external symbolic
medium for communicating human thoughts
and the way that it does that is because
there's some kind of General massing
function from our internal
representation so thought into this
external symbol system that's language
and so in this kind of older framework
what it means to understand language or
make meaning means mapping back from
external sentences that we hear into
structured internal representations
and what we explore in this paper is a
general proposal that casts the meanings
of language as these mappings or
probabilistic distributions over
expressions in a probabilistic
programming language
um and I'm going to come back after some
concrete examples to how I think this
relates to the conceptual World
semantics that Steve articulated in the
first talk because I think there are
actually some really deep connections
here the ways in which this might be one
way to formalize or enrich some of those
ideas
um and this architecture this proposal
here also suggests how language can be
integrated into a more General
architecture because it's one that
already starts out with as Alex
mentioned some kind of existing internal
modeling language whose goal is to
represent the world probabilistically
query those models and specify what it
means to draw coherent inferences over
them and it also suggests I think a
framework for formally modeling the
content of different kinds of sentences
and language as the kinds of
probabilistic programming Expressions
that they might map into
so
um uh and so in this paper We Begin by
exploring how this proposal might be
instantiated with respect to a bunch of
different domains of reasoning
um sorry including general public
reasoning but also reasoning about
relations or physics and social
situations and in all of these
um we're going to propose that we might
think about the language that
communicates General conceptual
knowledge about the world definitions or
causal knowledge as you know
constructing these public Expressions
that are those that build up
probabilistic generative models and then
in this framework observations in the
language like there is at least one red
mug in the scene or Charlie is Dana's
grandfather uh construct formal
conditioning statements which update the
state of this probabilistic model and
then questions map into query
Expressions that specify the formal
Target of probabilistic inference with
respects to a model
um and in this framework where thinking
essentially casts as probabilistic
reasoning we suggest that another way
that we can think about the role of a
language model one that's much smaller
like the language Network in the brain
is actually as a means of instantiating
this meaning function in a way that
we've really never had before to protect
these kinds of context specific and
previous discourse condition mappings
from sentences in natural language into
distributions over Expressions that
convey meaning in a probabilistic
programming language
and so I as a you know part of this
long-running disclaimer what I'm going
to be showing is a really minimal
implementation of this framework
um but really intended as a pointer to
different directions with which we might
scale this approach to implement a more
General interface between language and a
range of different core cognitive
domains so just to be clear concretely
in the examples that you see next our
meaning function is going to be
implemented using codecs right an open
AI model much smaller than the state of
the art right now that's trained to
learn joint distributions over language
and code and the probabilistic
programming language we're going to show
is church which is this very simple
public programming language
um that supports kind of very general
sample based inference procedures and
our goal is to demonstrate how this
framework might broadly interface
between language and a bunch of
different core contract domains
so first to illustrate the basic sense
in which a proposal like this might
allow language to update an agent's
beliefs and query a world model I'm
going to begin with a really simple toy
example that actually draws on a bunch
of Prior cognitive science experiments
um in which real people were asked to
draw various inferences about which
teams of players might win different
games of tug of war based on the games
that you'd previously seen players win
or lose and so this is older work from
Josh's group that demonstrated
um I think the sense in which this
normative model this normic model of
probabilistic inference actually in many
ways predicts the actual behaviors and
predictions made by humans
um using a very general probabilistic
model of um the mechanics of this tug of
war game and our goal here is to show
how our framework we can Implement an
interface between natural language and
all the core examples of this of this
older experiment
so just to go through here I think what
you're seeing and this little toy
example the world model that's being
defined on the screen is capturing the
basic causal relationship by which
properties of different
um human players might influence the
outcomes of different tournaments that
they play in tug of war so for instance
uh here uh we're modeling players as
having some internal inherent strength
value
um where strength varies approximately
normally but as this unobserved latent
variable over different kinds of players
and we also think of players as having
some kind of internal laziness value
which represents the percentages of time
that they actually don't act according
to their underlying strength
um and
um how do these variables determine the
outcomes that we observe of given games
of tug of war
um well you know the strength of a whole
team of players depends on the
cumulative sum of its player strengths
um but you know if a player is deciding
to be lazy in this game they might not
pull as hard as like head and whichever
team pulls with the most strength in the
given match is going to win that match
yeah
did you design The Primitives of strands
and laziness or codecs come up with The
Primitives themselves so in this one
we're looking at a model that's derived
from the older work so these are
designed but yes that's later in this
work we're going to show some examples
of how you can learn this kind of model
from someone just talking about it in
language like the definition that I just
gave
um right and so again you know this is a
really simple example but I think also
one that actually captures a surprising
amount of the basic causal knowledge
that people have if you tell them that
you're going to be listening to war
games but sometimes people can be lazy
and not pull us hard
so how do we go about relating language
in this domain
um right well one means by which we can
induce a simple notion of a meaning
function that actually fits the
definition we just gave is by
conditioning a language model both on
this context-specific generative World
model and on a few examples showing how
language is mapped into sampled
probabilistic programming expressions in
this domain
um and what we've done now right is
effectively induce this kind of
situation-specific contextual mapping
from arbitrary new sentences to
Expressions that conditions both on the
general prior distribution that codex is
over language and code and this kind of
specific discourse thinking context of
how language is being used in this
situation
and there are clearly other ways to do
this uh some of which we'll talk about
later but we're using this example to
illustrate um just how much you might be
able to do with this kind of minimal
implement
a notion of a model that translates
between language to code right so uh
what kinds of language might we say here
and how might we think about them in
relation to probabilistic current
Expressions well a general proposition
like Josh won against Leo gets
translated into or or might map we might
think of mapping or meaning a condition
statement an observation that Josh went
against Leo
um if we make subsequent observations
like then Josh went on to claim victory
against Alex we can continue to kind of
generally use this meaning function that
we've induced to turn that into a public
programming uh language that captured
the fact that Joshua against Alex if we
then say that you know even working
together as a team Leo and Alex still
couldn't beat Josh in this game about to
go for
um at this point if we want to answer a
query like okay wait how strong is Josh
um what we think of as thinking in this
uh situation is actually sampling uh
from the posterior over possible worlds
from the generative model that we just
defined subject to the observations that
we've just made and indeed that means
that the meaning of a sentence like how
strong is Josh is really a a structured
public stick inference query what is the
latent variable of uh that is Josh's
strength and what we see here is that
given his track record all these people
that he's beating even playing together
our inference is that Josh is likely a
good bit stronger than average and that
also means coherently we might expect
that a priori a new player we've never
seen like Gabe is going to be unlikely
to beat him
so if we ask what are the odds of Gabe
beating Josh we see that we think it's
somewhat unlikely
yes so
it seems like there's an interesting
thing here where there's also an
implicit question of what the word
strong means of this
and that like right it's like not a
number and it's kind of some like
competitive adjective it's like probably
a non-intersective
so I guess if that's something you think
about this framework or should I just be
kind of like ignoring this sort of issue
yeah well okay so I think there's a
number of ways that we can think about
that I mean so right so
the one sense we could say is like right
how strong is Josh isn't the answer to
how strong of Josh isn't a number rather
it's kind of this distribution over this
posterior distribution of various
underlying strength values that we
currently might infer that Josh has with
respect to the general model that we
have I think um another kind of popular
definition of various
um uncertain adjectives like a word like
strong right is that you have some
internal threshold value or the person
speaking has some kind of threshold
value
um that you uh must kind of jointly
infer with respect to the context in
what you've seen and some of the
examples that I'll actually give later
so right there's kind of a long line of
work in linguistics including some work
that treats that as like a pragmatic
inference I think some of the
interesting work that we'll show a
little bit later is that
um there are some ways in which you
might think of this mapping function
um as actually being a general one that
includes that notion of pragmatic
inference and also I think captures the
sense in which you know if you
continually are you really doing this
kind of pragmatic inference all the time
or do you actually in many general
settings like talking about the
strengths of people actually have some
kind of cached older notion of strike
that you can draw in and I think
actually this notion of large language
models of just being this learned
mapping function from language into
expressions and code can also capture
the sense in which that knowledge is
amortized away
um and you might not be having that
inference yeah Chris
he sort of just denying or ignoring what
makes people so excited about large
language models in their meeting
representation and ability
um to do in France
I mean because okay you've got sort of
call the probabilistic programming
language on the right hand
but in some sense the picture is still
this is semantic pausing like it was
2010 to 2015 and
yes you're using a large language model
but you're not actually using the
excitement of a large language models a
representation system yeah and I think
so probably each of us would have
different answers to this but part of
what we're hoping to paint out over the
course of this talk is I think some of
the ways in which actually
um right of course no one wants to say
we're going to go back to kind of the
brittleness of semantic person but I
think one thing that large language
models actually give us or one proposal
in this talk is that
um there are some aspects of the theory
uh kind of the classic notion of
linguistics and certainly class
technicians of semantic parsing that
actually normatively capture a lot of
what we really might want when we think
about so so one answer for an AI system
is well uh yes
um in some way we don't want to throw
certainly we don't want to throw away
everything that we're wearing from large
language models and I think one answer
to that is kind of the answer that I
gave to Jacob right
um if we think about uh not always you
know in these examples we're showing
this very direct system in which you
know we always start with language and
we always map into some sort of public
expression and that's where all the
thinking happens I might we might think
well that doesn't totally make sense
because there are lots of cases where as
you're saying we have every reason to
believe that large language models have
learned a lot of latent information they
can do a lot of they certainly have a
lot of latent conceptual information and
maybe to some degree they can even
perform certain kinds of limited
amortized inferences or reuse old
inferences
um that they've learned from what other
people have had and so in the second
part of this talk we're going to show
different ways in which well this
probabilistic programming language
itself doesn't necessarily need to be
something that's isolated from what
large language models have learned it
also can embed calls to
um large language models within it to
kind of draw on that store of knowledge
because you're doing this translation
into uh symbolic semantic representation
foreign
well right and also so no I think I
would say I
don't totally think that
uh we're using it or the sense in which
or I think there are some ways in which
um this kind of broader definition in
which you are saying well the meaning of
a distribute or the meaning of a
sentence in language isn't just one
prophesive programming expression right
that's what we're showing here for
pedagogical purposes but you might say
well okay right how are you going to
obey kind of the ambiguity of language
there are kinds of symptoms that are
definitionally ambiguous so one example
that we've looked like uh looked at are
sentences in which you say something
like Josh beat Alex and Leo right and
you might ask well you know that's kind
of a classic syntactic construction does
that mean that uh Josh beat Alex and Leo
and they were playing on the same team
or Josh Pete Alex and then Josh went on
to beat Leo and uh what we see are
generally what you might say is well the
meaning of that sentence actually
shouldn't be picking one of the one
expression or the other
um it should be kind of the distribution
over those possible horses and that
distribution also shouldn't just be
something that we can determine in this
totally context and sensitive way it
should actually depend on all the
previous patterns in the discourse so if
someone's continually been using this
conjunctive and to refer to
um you know teams of players playing
together we should take that kind of
discourse bias into account and I think
actually
um right this provides or thinking of
large language models as kind of
generally Having learned this broad
joint distribution but one that can be
kind of conditioned quite richly both on
you know this the content of this
generative model so you know it's not
trying to come up with a universal
definition of strength it's not even
necessarily trying to come up with a
universal definition of any of these
words it's thinking about how they might
map contextually into the best possible
um expression in the context of a
particular local model of adult for a
particular situation I think is uh you
know obviously related to but by
attempting to address some of the
um the brittleness challenges of
semantic parsing in the past I think
another answer to this right is that
part of the problem of semantic person
previously has been actually that the
mapping functions have historically uh
been difficult to get right whether you
were thinking about those as kind of old
hard-coded grammars or you know many of
the attempts to kind of learn these
things via very domain specific
supervision so you want to have a
semantic cursor for a particular
robotics domain you need a thousand
examples of
um sentences about that particular
robotics domain and a thousand paired
with a thousand examples of um
programs that are operating on that
particular domain what we're seeing here
is I think something that says no what
it means to learn language generally is
to learn kind of this General mapping
right between language and some kind of
underlying representation
um and also right one reason why we
might want a system like this is because
we want to be able to condition
coherently on information that's not
just coming from language
um and uh right we want to think about
how a general substrate in which we the
only yes we might be told that Josh won
against Leo but we might also be
watching videos that give us information
about Josh's strength
um that conveyor observations we might
also have seen pictures uh like the ones
in the stimuli that we saw before
demonstrating the results of previous
outcomes of matches and I think uh you
know one thing that suggests is we want
this kind of General uh substrate
um in which we can think about how those
are observations including the
observations from language but without
prioritizing language in any way I think
are are coherently considered
um but
so I think it depends on what part of
semantic pursing you
um or yeah I think the answer to that
depends on what part of semantic cursing
we think of as being the source of the
brittleness
um that caused us to um throw that that
Paradigm into question
yeah and maybe I'll I'll just offer one
more perspective so one part of it is is
what Leo is saying traditional semantic
parting is brittle in two ways one is do
you have broad coverage of language that
you can parse into your system and two
is like how how broad coverage are the
set of query like the set of semantic
queries that you can actually answer and
I think what you're pointing out is this
doesn't seem to address the second
source of brittleness which is that your
system can only answer certain things it
can only reason about certain things
um brutalness of the formal
representation language that you're
using that
um large language model representations
right
right so I think
my sort of
take on that is uh from from a kind of
AI engineering perspective is
um
sort of to a branching in two directions
one is I think we have made some
progress that you know this is not
really evoking probably uh toward
systems that within restricted domains
um Can reason coherently and
probabilistically uh about a wide range
of queries so we have systems uh like uh
this inference ql system that uses
non-parametric Bays to analyze huge data
tables and come up with a model of that
system that uh or of your data that can
answer all sorts of questions like oh um
uh you know uh
show me like which people in this data
set are like probably overpaid given
their experience or something like that
so in the same way that people are kind
of excited about using natural language
or using language models to parse into
SQL right because so much data is in SQL
and there's a it's a very sequel is a
very expressive language for asking
questions about that data
um when we have a probabilistic system
like a good probabilistic model of that
data under the hood it enables
conversational patterns that are not
enabled when you have like SQL as the
database because we expect our
conversational Partners to have coherent
beliefs about the world to update those
beliefs in response to new evidence that
we give it to be able to report
uncertainty
um and and make sort of modal judgments
and so one engineering path is to take
those kinds of systems and uh sort of
build conversational interfaces to them
that behave more like an intelligent
person would behave and can draw
inferences that you might not draw
uh if you're just talking to a SQL back
in the other path that sort of we'll
talk about in
the next part of the talk is how can we
use those representations that language
models have learned to make the
probabilistic inferences uh more
interesting and more robust less brittle
uh without sort of totally embracing the
other kind of brittleness which is the
kind of brittleness that language models
seem to have right now which is that
they draw that they don't really
necessarily reason with coherent
probabilistic beliefs so maybe yeah
yeah well so so right so in in the
interest of time I'm actually going to
like skip through some of the rest of
this example which I think is just more
of what you've seen but but one sense in
which I think yeah maybe a third part of
the answer to Chris I would say is that
uh
right you know yeah I think part of what
this is trying to do is explore some of
the ways in which we might answer ways
and right without giving an answer in
all the uh ways in which we might answer
the ways in which language models
themselves are brittle with respect to
what we also want from a model of
intelligence right we might suspect that
when we answer ask questions like this
really what we are trying to do is
specify some kind of normative query
um that captures formally a sense of
well we want something like the
posterior with respect to some kind of
internal model of the world and you know
this is kind of the simplest means or
this is a very simple example of how we
might formally impose that kind of
structure
um but one that I think can be
elaborated on
um uh depending on the kinds of
Primitives and the ways in which you're
thinking about what it is that the
probabilistic programs can express right
so one way in which we might think about
doing that
um is by thinking about problems
um that themselves have access to other
kinds of means of calling other
different um mechanisms and cognition
right so I think I would draw a contrast
here between the notion of the large
language model as a controller the one
that's making the decisions about when
to write little Snippets of code and to
execute them when to call out to little
planners and incorporate them or stuff
like the the minds I work right where
there's a language model it decides when
to call out to a physics simulator but
the way it interprets the outputs of
that physics simulator is to paste those
back into the language model context and
try to draw inferences on them in turn
rather in this kind of framework right
what you can kind of see a
um or yeah the direction that this
framework would be pointing towards is
to say well uh on the other hand we
already have languages that allow us to
do things like build expressive
generative models over three-dimensional
scenes that also capture things that we
might want only from perception like
knowledge about how the shapes of
objects tend to occlude each other uh or
incorporate Rich models of physics or
that model theory of Mind as taking
place recursively in thinking about
agents who themselves have beliefs about
their own internal World models and are
actually choosing their actions as
planners right and in this kind of
framework
um you can point the way towards a kind
of model that says well how is it that I
might incorporate language into these
kinds of models sitting alongside these
other kind of observations that I might
make right so how uh might I think about
the meaning of
um images that I want to generate that
specify specific constraints or
um Imagination or right okay go ahead
Jacob yeah I just had a clarification
question so you were talking earlier
about having this beating function
um and then I think also we're
mentioning something about uh like
depend understand which we should do
that uh is that here or is the median
function going to come later
um and are you so that's really the
first question then the other
clarification is so are these statements
actually just being programmatically
created from codex by prompting the the
text that was up yes that's right so by
meaning function in this uh framework we
say well there's kind of two general
missions of a meeting function there's a
general joint uh prior right that codex
is already that it's learned between
language and code and then there's this
kind of context specific
um meaning function in the sense that
it's conditioned on whatever's in the
prompt the generative model and some
examples of how language uh relates to
expressions of this domains that's the
meaning function and yes all these
examples that you're seeing are one
sample from that distribution
um right
and one of the things that I want to
point to here right is it does I think
it suggests a framework or another means
of thinking about what it means for
language to construct New Concepts from
definitions or even come to construct
New World models from thinking like
somebody in the beginning asks right so
how for instance might we think about
enriching an existing structured
relational model with Concepts that we
learn from language so for example if we
consider kind of a formal model of
kinship relations
um we might say uh that
um well you know the generative model of
this domain is itself represented as a
proboscope program it captures both the
causal means by which
people give rise to their children and
also the definitions or one notion of
the definitions of what it means to be
something like a sister or a father with
respect to this core notion of how
family trees come to be and so if you
take this kind of General notion of the
meaning of language as being the
distribution over Expressions that
creates in a probabilistic programming
language you might start to think how we
can formally think about relating
definitions for various kinds of
relational terms you know and uncle is
the brother of one's parent or the
husband that one's Aunt a pibbling is a
gender-neutral term for an aunt or Uncle
that's the siblings of one's parent
um or this relational notion of a sister
of one's father from a language that's
actually not found anywhere on the
internet and I think the core thing that
we want to suggest here right is why do
we even have definitions at all
um well one reason is be or one notion
of what it even means to have learned
the definition of this term is that it
should drive coherently
um all of the downstream inferences that
you make with that term and it should uh
graft onto the conceptual knowledge that
you already have and so you can think
about
um forming new sentences directly uh
that refer to someone's Pani or one's
pebbling in this situation and expecting
them to draw both on your existing
conceptual knowledge of what it even
means to
um have a family tree as well as all the
other conceptual terms for kinship that
you may already have
um and the same framework also suggests
one mechanism by which we might
formalize what it means to learn World
models from language so as I mentioned
if we return to the situation that opens
this talk
um tug of war games uh we might think
about how the definition that I gave
when I sat up here at the podium right
saying there are people whose strength
levels vary from person to person
um people have a percentage of time in
which they're lazy
um strengths of the teams depend on the
underlying strengths of their uh of the
members of that team and whether one
team beats another just depends on which
team pulls stronger that match in this
kind of setting is actually uh language
right is building up the actual
generative model itself and you might
think of a system like this that both
learns these kinds of theories from
language and then uh you know is
appending to this kind of local
problem-based context to answer
arbitrary questions like the kinds that
we gave or condition on various
observations like Josh being stronger
than Leo so with respect to this kind of
local notion
um of uh what strength means in this
particular problem context that we're
thinking about
um in the interest of time why don't we
just jump on to your section thanks
um so uh
so um we've just been talking about how
natural language can sort of uh be
interpreted or semantically parsed um to
a probabilistic language of thought
um but we haven't talked about how
cognition itself uh which is sort of
we've been talking about as the product
of general purpose probabilistic
inference Machinery might interact with
language uh cognitively or how our tools
for uh are you know our algorithms for
inference our model representations
might benefit from recent advances in
language models
so
um in the rest of the talk I'll sort of
talk about this also very preliminary
work that we just presented at a
workshop at icml
um that is more about a role for natural
language and language models in this
part of the picture
um and one reason to think that natural
language must play some role in this
part of the picture
is that sometimes we set ourselves
reasoning tasks to specifications
what it would mean to solve the
reasoning task correctly must involve
natural language so for example if you
have an iPhone you might have used the
visual voicemail feature which
automatically but somewhat incompletely
transcribes your voicemails and um these
transcripts have gaps marked by
underscore sequences of varying lights
indicating Apple couldn't quite work out
what was said
um and an inference task that I
sometimes face is squinting at these
transcripts and trying to think what
could the person have said during those
bits that it didn't transcribe correctly
and uh is it worth my time to listen to
this voicemail or am I pretty certain
that I got all the uh all the relevant
information from the part of the
transcript that I've seen
uh
so even if I'm representing that kind of
inference problem in some kind of
probabilistic language of thought and
not in natural language it must
reference natural language because a key
part of the reasoning that I'm doing is
about how long those gaps are about what
words could go in those gaps how they
could semantically and syntactically
with the words around them
um
uh and there are a lot of other tasks
like this where the specification of
some reasoning problem must in some way
involve language maybe we're writing
something that has to obey certain
structural constraints like a poem uh or
code
um maybe we're puzzling over a message
from our advisor trying to infer all the
different meanings consistent with what
they said uh maybe we're trying to
figure out how to put together some
words that we predict could achieve some
desired effect in a listener
um and Beyond the fact that some
inference problems implicate language in
their specification it seems like at
least sometimes we sort of use language
for thinking right uh rubber duck
debugging is when we uh successfully
debug something that's been stopping us
by just talking about it uh to ourselves
or to a rubber duck
um and I think this is the intuition
also behind sort of Chain of Thought
scratch pad
those kinds of uh Innovations in in
language model land
but one reason why I'm drawing this
distinction between task specification
and algorithm is that uh this has long
been a really important distinction in
probabilistic modeling and inference and
it's something that I think we lose when
we move just to asking a language model
a question and hoping that it gives us
the the right answer so you know in in
the kind of work that our lab does in
modeling and inference
um we sort of separately create a model
probabilistic program that encodes a
task specification as a posterior
distribution we want to sample from and
separately an inference program that
compositionally encodes some kind of
algorithm or strategy for solving that
inference task and when you use a
probabilistic programming language to do
this you've got some benefits from
taking this approach of separating model
and inference we know that we have
soundness theorems guaranteeing that as
computation increases the inference is
going to approach the posterior we have
automated tools and tests for measuring
how accurate our inferences are relative
to the model uh with finite computation
and we also have gradient estimators
that help us tune any parameters of our
inference programs to better to be
better inference algorithms and Beyond
being useful properties for engineering
these guarantees also reflect some key
aspects of human cognition we can often
think more to reach more accurate
conclusions we can critically evaluate
the extent to which our current
hypotheses actually make sense given our
model of the world and if we repeatedly
face the same kind of inference task we
can train ourselves to get better at
solving it
so something we've begun to explore is
whether adding llms to this picture
might let us both specify various
linguistic tasks as formal probabilistic
models and enhance our inference
algorithms by letting them do some of
their thinking using language as a tool
so I'll first talk about the the
modeling side of things
so we all know that an auto regressive
language model defines a probability
distribution over sequences of tokens
um but we rarely just want to sample
that unconditional uh distribution
you know in the same way that in order
to use a stat solver we need to reduce
the problem we care about to a SAT
formula here's a language model we need
a reduction from the task instance that
we care about
to uh a prompt
and the idea is that we're saying that
the conditional distribution of the
language model condition of that prompt
is somehow a good good specification of
the task that we want to solve or a good
approximation to the task that we want
to solve but unlike the reductions to
sat of course
um this reduction is lossy one problem
is that sort of hard constraints sort of
instructions that we give the the
language model might be uh you know it
might fail to follow them so this
conditional distribution P task
um uh is not really the specification
that we have in mind it's just some
close thing that we can get
um
another problem is that the entropy of
this distribution may not meaningfully
respect reflect uncertainty so you may
have seen in the uh gpt4 paper that
um on multiple language tasks sorry
multiple choice tasks where uh there are
some multiple choice question and the
language model is asked to Output A B C
or D before they did any rlhf and
instruction tuning if they create a
calibration plot where they plot sort of
uh you know
of all the answers in which GPT was you
know point four percent confident how
often was that the correct answer right
gpt4 is strikingly well calibrated and
that's what you might expect from a
model that's doing a very good job of
next token prediction of matching the
distribution of language when it's
uncertain the loss function is telling
it it should allocate its mass its
probability Mass according to that
distribution whereas after our early
test the calibration is shot and uh this
is also what you might expect even if
the humans uh who were sort of providing
the uh the human feedback in rlhs
preferred the right answer okay the
distribution that you get after uh after
performing rlhf with the objective
that's commonly used for rhf sort of
creates a reduction in temperature it's
equivalent to reducing the temperature
um of the parts where the human feedback
is exactly aligned with
sort of the correct answer
and so it becomes overconfident
uh and you know this is very prompt
dependent I don't mean to say that this
is like always going to happen if you go
and use GPT but I went and used GPT 3.5
to do this like infilling task and it
did it correctly but also every time
that I generated at temperature one it
gave me basically the same answer
so if I want to think of this
distribution as sort of representing
uncertainties that I can make decisions
about whether to listen to my voicemail
because it might contain things I don't
know uh this P task is not up to that up
to that task
so our idea is to instead of reducing to
a prompt reduced to a probabilistic
program that may call language model
that may call a language model which is
sort of a more flexible way of
specifying what the task distribution we
want to sample from um and I'm I I know
I'm running low on time but the idea is
that these models
and permits calls to the language model
with conditioning statements and other
logic so in this probabilistic program
for this infilling task
uh it is in a loop going through each
sort of blank in in the that we need to
infill sampling a random number of
tokens that uh that should fill that
spot
sampling those tokens and then observing
the next sort of fixed fragment
um or conditioning on the next part
being a fixed fragment and this just
lets us specify
a model that doesn't just have a prefix
prompt that sort of has a prompt with
points in it
um I haven't said yet how we're going to
sample this but the idea is that this
defines a specification for the task
that we want and similarly we have
programs that sort of specify a variety
of tasks that involve sort of thinking
with language right uh we can condition
on hard constraints if we want to parse
into a formal grammar or write a Haiku
we can do kind of a product of experts
model using multiple prompts so maybe I
want to think about a fun fact that's
about both London and Paris well you
could just ask the prompt hey please
give me a fun fact about both London and
Paris but you could also create a
product of experts model where it has to
come up with a completion that is both a
completion to the sentence a fun fact
about London is and the completion to
the sentence a fun fact about Paris is
and that's kind of a hybrid where the
idea of and and both is symbolically
encoded but we're still using the
language models representation of
knowledge about fun facts uh and and
these things similarly we can sort of
represent reward steering or classifier
guidance by conditioning by sort of soft
conditioning on a reward function
um
and we can also include things like hey
please generate a gloss of this code
that when I try to semantic parse it
back into
into code gives me the same code I
started with things like that
so those are model programs
um for specifying various tasks we need
inference algorithms for actually
sampling from these distributions and um
so far we've been focusing on sequential
Monte Carlo inference algorithms uh and
we kind of have a default version of
this method and then fancier versions of
this method that are necessary for
harder tasks in many ways sequential
Monte Carlo looks like meme search you
kind of keep multiple hypotheses around
you extend them you re-weight them
Accord in a model specific way
and then you resample which is kind of
like the part of beam search where you
sort of down sample from your your big
expanded theme back to your beam size
but unlike beam search
uh sequential Monte Carlo as you scale
up the number of hypotheses that you're
using instead of converging to an ARG
Max of your objective function converges
to the posterior distribution sampling
from the posterior distribution
and this sort of default version of SMC
has worked for a few simple tasks that
we've tried it on
um for example if I want a completion
that follows my favorite physicist is
probably and my favorite writer is
probably equally well SMC can give me
Richard Feynman I really admire how he
communicates complex ideas so clearly
um or if I want to finish the FED says
but only using words less than five
letters I get the FED says it will taper
but the rate Heights are still but rate
hikes are still years away or something
like that and it's worth noting that if
you do something like token masking to
enforce this constraint you know you
just
forbid the language model from
generating anything that's longer than
five letters you get all sorts of weird
completions uh it's different from the
posterior here you get completions that
you know set up an idiom that it could
only complete if it used a word longer
than five letters or something like that
right and then it just gets very
confused and writes dot dot read more or
something it tries to come up with some
context in which the sentence would be
cut off early
um and for infilling tasks we get a
variety of samples that sort of uh fit
semantically and syntactically with uh
uh with the text but infilling tasks can
be made much harder than this one so I
don't want to claim that this method
yeah it solves all these fling tests so
for harder tasks we think we're going to
need to use fancier sequential Monte
Carlo algorithms and both of these sort
of steps can actually be extended in
various ways we can use better proposal
distributions uh and sort of
um better re-weighting strategies that
are trying to guess okay are we on the
path to getting a good sample here and
we think that techniques that have
already been developed in the literature
for proposing good things in uh in line
with constraints or
sort of discriminating whether we're
likely to land in a constraint could be
good ingredients to put here but the
important thing is and I'll this is at
the very end the important thing is all
of those things become part of the
inference program
and there are still guarantees that as
we scale up the number of particles
we're still targeting the original
specification of the model so all of
those heuristics or biases don't sort of
we don't just trust them blindly we
don't hand the keys to those techniques
we still have a specification that we
can understand okay I'll stop there
thanks
[Applause]
a little bit behind time so unless there
is a burning question learning question
no burning questions let's pray for for
uh for tea and maybe zachar torta and
you guys can talk to the uh the speakers
uh and uh at 11 30 we are going to